did you miss me hey youtubers it's
Charlie who luck week continues with my
list of top 5 Doctor Who Christmas
specials this will cover everything from
series 1 to now in case you have no idea
what wholock week is I'm doing a special
week of Doctor Who and Sherlock videos
just in honor of the Christmas special
and Sherlock series 3 coming back so be
sure to subscribe to get everything
there's gonna be a lot of awesome stuff
and I'll be giving away some stuff for
free tomorrow I'll explain it during my
Wednesday videos but I'm gonna be
picking a random commenter and each of
my Wednesday videos just to give away
gift certificate to even international
viewers so everyone qualifies Geronimo
let's go top 5 Doctor Who Christmas
specials number 5 the snowmen this had a
great original story and an amazing
guest cast including Richard II Grant
and Sir Ian McKellen
as the voice of the great intelligence a
lot of Steven Moffat scribbles were
based on adapted stories with a lot of
very Anglophile Dickensian touches but
one of the things that I really loved
about this special was that it was an
original story and it introduced a new
companion even though a similar thing
happened during runaway bride I liked
Clara's introduction to the doctor much
better than Donna's because Clara called
the doctor to action instead of the
other way around plus the doctor as
Ebenezer Scrooge was hilarious I loved
his outfit pre Clara I was a little bit
bummed when he dumped the top hat pre
series 7 though number 4 the next Doctor
so this was a bit of a play on Tennant
announcing that he was leaving the
series after the following year Russell
T Davies deserves a giant high-five
though for his use of Cybermen the cyber
king and an amazing guest cast something
about these specials makes it so much
easier for the BBC to get the best
actors david morsi was amazing as the
faux human doctor and dervalloc irwin
was one of the best human villains i've
seen on any series of Doctor Who mind
you human villains every time you watch
david morrissey on the walking dead now
just remember he has a memory imprints
of the doctor rattling around in his
head maybe that's why he ended up going
so crazy and killing all those people in
Woodbury number three the Christmas
invasion there's so many reasons why
this belongs in the top three it was the
very first Doctor Who Christmas special
something that American shows don't do
by the way it was David Tennant's first
full outing as the doctor it proved the
change can totally be a good thing and
prove that despite a thicker axe
invasion the doctor can still celebrate
Christmas the episode was a huge test
for Russell T Davies and David Tennant
and they both passed with flying colors
and what a bold move
keeping the doctor virtually comatose
for the majority of the story how much
did you love when the doctor saved the
day in his pajamas Doctor Who is a lot
of things but most of all it is pure fun
number two the end of time after three
series and six specials end of time was
the passing of the guard to Matt Smith
which is one of the reasons why I think
they opted to make it a two-hour special
question how do you top the transition
from 9 to 10 answer by bringing in the
Time Lords and the master the Time Lords
is a story device or actually a very big
deal and they've already come back in
the 50th anniversary episode even though
it caused a lot of head-scratching
continuity problems with end of time but
most of all people ask when is the
master going to come back and my number
one Christmas special a Christmas Carol
this was a very close Doctor Who
adaptation of Charles Dickens with
another amazing villain Michael Gambon I
loved how the doctor basically became
Katherine's Jacob Marley the reason why
I chose this is my number one pick was
because it's the best Doctor Who story
about Christmas it's so perfect that the
science fiction aspects of the story
almost don't even need to be there for
everything to make sense I'm interested
to see how the time of the doctor stacks
up against Christmas invasion and
Christmas Carol as a holiday story the
episode itself has been hyped so much
that I'm expecting it to crack my list
of all-time top ten episodes be sure to
write your own favorite Christmas
special in the comments below and why
you picked it is it because it's a
Christmas story or just because you like
the episode itself tomorrow like I said
I'll be posting my review of the
Christmas special be sure to subscribe
to get it
I'll be giving away a gift certificate
to a random commenter so you might have
a chance to win something for Christmas
right now click here for more details on
who lock week in the videos I'm doing
and click here for a breakdown of the
Christmas special trailer thank you so
much for watching Happy Holidays I'll
see you guys tomorrow
you